smetti agli arrampicati su ogni cazzo di
cosa polipo bene a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono favi
jane ed oggi siamo tornati su 8 da
teheran con i massi che dovevo tipo non
dicono che cafè devo fare perché questa
si chiama la danza sulla banana e
famosissima nel mondo ragazzi erano
rimasti ragazzi che avevo salvato
praticamente la mia famiglia da dei
mostri in credit a un cuoco non si sa
che parcheggiare un como in casa è
praticamente ragazzi che cazzo fatto
razzi ottima anche la testa prova ad
arrangiarmi come posso non so se questa
ti va bene ci provo non so se perfetto
ma anche ragazzi una banana dalla
discutibile utilità non sapere che cosa
posso usare la banana ma io ho qualche
idea alla stella grafico che non so se
può funzionare non ho idea ma io ci
provo a no perfetto non era ok allora io
avevo immaginato altre cose banana dead
abbiamo fatto un manichino bellissimo 32
più figo ci siamo 8 detto etico di prima
che è successo fermi tumido lato di un
polipo e grazie al cazzo se sei un umano
allora devi devi superare questo test
ragazzi non fare un test scala questa
scala fa molto ridere come battuta
ragazzi state ridendo tutti vero ragazzi
l'umorismo visto gioco è una delle cose
che mi lascia più perplesso di sempre
non si capisce che cazzo è successo
ragazzi perché era tutto a fuoco
devo salvare il mio fratello vieni con
me fratello mio ti salverò io ragazzi
stonando foto scusate se non volete un
po il profitto deve uscire di qua
perdonami donna d'onna se ci proverò di
essere un essere umano
adesso vai giù brutto stronzo come cazzo
faccia e vabbè sono salito lavoro salito
la scala [ __ ] ma fermo visto di
incastrato non devi fidarti sotto la
scala porta sfiga 8.1 rendo sto male
ecco vedi maverick e sei stupido
l'avevo detto no che portava sfiga stare
sotto le scale cos'è sta roba su si
riporta perfetta per questa la morte più
giusta mi sembra ovvio sono salito se è
perfetto che bello che sei che
trasformerà in un strusci ragazzi
sarebbe questa la scena più epica di
sempre peggio del signore degli anelli
mi ha preso il mio fronte hai ucciso mio
fratello che la farò pagare brutto
bastardo non ci tocca a mio fratello non
si tocca
che è l'unico un ricordo che cazzo i
miei figli e prendi chi sta giraffe in
faccia queste macchinine tutta dov era
quello io questa penso sia la trama più
bella che abbiamo inseguito in un
videogioco sono sicuro che vede temi
sulla parola e questa è la mia splendida
moglie e alla fine il balcone anzi così
che cazzo vanno bene mio fratello mia
moglie se l'ha fatto mio fratello
ragazzo in un assenso non avete mai
visto un polipo con le corna da oggi si
ragazzi ormai sono spaventatissimo
dall'andare avanti perché ci sono delle
bucce di banana che che vuole farmi
cadere ragazzi
ciao
[Musica]
tutto a posto amico mio ragazzi questa
la mandiamo a paperissima l'ho presa
piano non mettere piede sulla banana
madonna che cazzo ragazzi io io a motore
da prefetto l'ultima già che ci siamo
proviamo questa non c'è due senza tre
buca 1 ragazzi ogni lezione di biliardo
oggi fa vijay vi insegnerà come
diventare dei professionisti a questo
gioco prima cosa ragazzi bisogna
avvicinarsi al tavolo con molta
leggerezza perfetto se bisogna prendere
la pallina bianca è con questa bisogna
buttare in buca tutte le altre palline
cos'è ricordatevi ragazzi che il
biliardo un gioco molto calmo e come
tale va giocato giustamente pallina di
ma basta 60 a posso tirare non ci credo
il portiere 37 posto tirare le freccette
ragazzi certo so che c'è i muscoli di un
mollusco è questo mi sembra abbastanza
ovvio ma ce la puoi fare io credo in te
nel cuore mio fai vedere la tua potenza
i muscoli 321 ce l'ho fatta agazzi penso
che avete capito che orto detto un
professionista a tutti cazzo di giochi
miliardo freccette non c'è niente che
non riesca a fare la rara specie di
polipi danzerini escavatori si trova
nelle case più disparate d'america opera
silenziosamente nelle case di tutti
grazie sotterrato delle banane amico
mirò ragazzi questuomo ha dei problemi
io l'ho sempre pensato e qualcuno mi
deve spiegare perché cazzo ha sotterrato
quattro chili di banane nel soggiorno
amico mio guardo già visto di tutto non
i denti e cazzuto abbia sotterrato qui
sotto ma qualsiasi contatto vallate
un'esca va da dio a una una chiave
perfetta forse questa mi serve
effettivamente mai così qualcosa di
decente effettivamente la sotterrato ma
sono curioso di vedere che cazzo ceco
indietro cosa allora adesso a basso
presto abbasso questo fermi e banale non
servivano vero mi porto anche la testa
di mio fratello
e già che ci siamo perfetto ragazzo c'è
qui dietro ho paura di vedere che cosa
c'è chi perché c'è il cuoco senti zio ma
non puoi nasconderti dietro gli armadi
di casa mia mente rame n'è per nessuno
chi cazzo fatto sparito ragazza la
smetti di imitare michael jackson cazzo
di polpo ora dobbiamo cos'è sta roba
c'è un pannello fermi donna d'onna
charlip c'è
ok ho aperto anche se mou società ha
perfezionato la bolla meglio così
ragazze devo dirla tutta non sa neanche
che cazzo sto facendo ma sto andando
avanti così praticamente senza motivo
come premere un pulsante faiotto dead
ciao ragazzi quando premere un pulsante
voi non dovete fare così dovete fare
così non funziona perché ed imparate
ragazzi imparati a perché un gioco
educativo devo aggiungere la porta prima
che si chiuda è un'impresa ragazzi già
posso fare se il polpo sottiletta può
aspettare devo superare i laser pur
fantastico non poteva andare meglio di
così
mi ha presa mi ha pure preso mia mi sta
per riprendere ragazzo è possibile devo
fare james bond con sfido chiunque a
fare james bond con un polipo
impossibile cazzo farlo ho trovato dei
governi odio schiacciato da una mole di
scatole inutili vai avanti così madonna
mi sto mi sto facendo malissimo anni
porta sono il james bond migliore del
mondo
dai su non piangere stavo scherzando
senti ci alziamo ora che c'è la nutella
di lana bravo ha capito subito per chi
cazzo che cosa qua
raga qualcuno chiami un cazzo di
esorcista vi prego 8 della fumato
qualcosa fa fermati in nome del dio dei
polipi e io io credo che tu abbia bevuto
qualcosa di nascosto non ti ho visto ma
non lo fare più o forse per passare
questo film mi piace troppo in modo sexy
che hai di camminare cazzo mi sto in due
rimorchi così la ragazza ammettilo
ammettilo cos'è sta roba da far non ci
credo non ci credo
ragazzi e lui e james mondo ormai non ci
sono più dubbi non ci sono più fottuti
dubbi e james bond
praga mi dà soddisfazioni quest'uomo ed
è un uomo cento e affidatevi devo
passare di qua mamma mia
la spia migliore del mondo caso le
tattiche e lui ma da una donna se si si
oddio io lo amo io lo amo è un genio è
un j cos'è sta roba
la pista di pattinaggio e un sensore
lato b spiega te che cazzo di assessore
c'è questo cammina nell'aria ball si
capisce un cazzo andiamo avanti
ragazzino non si sta capendo una mazza
che dove siamo
c'è un punch è un pacco è però c'è
scritto per fa vj lo devo aprire i blog
poi prenderlo non il blocco tutto il
parco per anno devo farlo a non è non
era per me io devo farlo a qualcuno del
cazzo siamo cazzo fitto 8 dead calo
mi stavo divertendo troppo maledizione
tanti ragazzi l'unico gioco che si gioca
anche nei titoli di coda non l'ho mai
visto tanto si possono più alle fragole
perché ragazzi si sta improvvisando
ballerina di hard di danza moderna rega
gli occhi non ho parole per descrivere
questa roba
entrato lui balla c'è e va beh non
importa ragazzi non mi piace per il suo
ballo fantastico io voglio veramente
complimentarmi con i creatori di questo
gioco perché sono dei po tutti i geni
perché non lo so che cazzo gli è venuto
in mente per fare sta roba
ragazzi non so chi cazzo abbiamo fumato
per far questo ma di sicura roba buona
anche ragazzi fatemi sapere se volete
che io faccia il dlc perché c'è anche il
dlc gli starò pace che ci crediate o no
penso sia epica un corpi di questo non
lo so perché non l'ho visto ma lo farò
di sicuro se volete fatemelo sapere nei
commenti soprattutto fatemi sapere se
avete trovato un senso a tutto questo è
cosa al solito ragazzi 6 video è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a faccia di facebook come non i
video trovate la descrizione ha senso da
christie's crete vino ci rivediamo in un
prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]